[Music]
hello my name is Matt Lacroix I'm the
marketing manager for Massey Ferguson
hey equipment and if you haven't met the
best silage cutter Baylor's in the
market let me introduce you to the RB
Series loading mesh into your RB series
is really easy we have a convenient
ladder that folds down you can hop up
onto the platform a storage roll goes
here and under the side shield here we
show that in a minute but to load the
mesh all you have to do is flip your
mesh over in there now let's go up here
and see how the mesh system works so you
have your mesh in the holder cradle you
flip it over into its working position
your out your mesh through these bars
and you go across this foam roller here
this foam roll or may look like you're
gonna take it to a kid's pool actually
it has a very good use and what it does
it spreads the mesh evenly across the
entire Bell width now that we've loaded
our mesh the ladder folds about easily
with your platform
and since safety is always key remember
your tailgate shut off valve is here we
have it in the lock position now so will
not open and close before you unlock it
since we're in this area we'll talk
about the split gearbox here the split
gearbox is original design to us and
what it does it evenly transfers the
power from your pto
to each side of the baler therefore
you're equally driven on both sides the
pickup on the RB series is very
heavy-duty let me show you some key
features that makes this a really great
pickup so you have a wind guard roller
here helps keep that prop mat compressed
as you go in and along the wind row
we've got offset teeth on the ends now
you may ask probably have offset teeth
the reason being is we have these augers
back here these augers going to move the
crop over because the pickup is wider
than the bill chamber so it's going to
move the crop over
so these teeth are offset so it
constantly feeds that auger is there
waiting to the next set of teeth comes
in and from this angle you can see the
front of our rotor
these are silage cutter round balers so
that means the rotor is gonna spin and
pull crop across the knives
now when we look at service in a little
bit we'll get to see a better view of
the knives so once you've loaded your
mesh upfront you need to put some
tension on that mesh
so it doesn't free will you can use this
handle here and you have two different
lobes depending on what size mesh you
load into it since these Baylor's are
four feet wide you can use a 48 inch or
52 inch these Baylor's hold three rolls
of mesh to storage one being used to
very unique features of our RB series is
protection of your knives when they're
engaged also the Hydra flex floor and
the drop floor our knives are controlled
by hydraulics they're hydraulically
controlled up and the hydraulically
protected if you come across an
obstruction such as a rock in the field
as you're going through the field your
window may not be perfect even all the
way across so you'll have different
amounts of crop coming into your pickup
that's why we have the hydro flex floor
this floor moves up and down as the
windrow density changes throughout the
field now if you ever do come across an
obstruction they cannot fit through
there
and it gets plugged don't worry no do
you get out of the cab from the monitor
in the cab you can automatically lower
the floor what will happen is the knives
will disengage themselves the floor will
come down you reengage your PTO the
material that is lodged will go into the
bell chamber then you raise the floor
back up re-engage your knives and away
you go
all of us have had to dig out of the
chamber that's plugged in August and
it's super hot
this will keep that from happening now I
have the tailgate locked out
always make sure safety first you lock
out your tailgate before you service
your knives or any part of your bill
chamber as you can see here we have four
endless belts for positive traction now
let's look into the knives these
Baylor's come standard with 17 knives
you can engage zero knives eight knives
nine knives or 17 now if you want a
different combination other than those
you have to come back here and manually
remove the knives now if for some reason
you want to keep the knives out always
you can get these optional blanks to put
in there let me show you how the process
is done to remove your knives slide this
back and there's a holder on the front
and back as you can see it holds in the
front and the rear and the
a magnet that holds it and lined up for
you and to put a blank in goes in this
way this goes on your front bar and once
you get on that bar slides in place the
RB series comes with 17 serrated knives
and since these are serrated if you do
need to sharpen them you'd do that from
the backside only and I would suggest go
ahead and get ordering 17 more knives so
you can keep a fresh set with you at all
times and there is storage on side the
baler for that this is the knife locking
handle here it is in the lock position
and then we move it to the unlock
position to remove the knives when you
look at the back of the baler here you
may see these circles and wonder what
those circles are for when you actually
are using these Baylor's in the field
you run the tailgate and float the
reason we run the tailgate and float is
as the bail grows that tailgate sinks
down as you can see and it moves down
and that keeps constant tension on the
springs on the side to keep your chains
lubricated we have a reservoir here a
pump down here and it automatically
pumps oil into your lines we have a
combination of brushes and pads on your
chains to keep them lubricated and
running smoothly to make sure your mesh
is applied effectively we have a powered
mesh roller so what this does it powers
the mesh into the chamber to get it
started quickly and effectively while
we're here we can also look at our mesh
tensioning system there's a couple of
changes you can make in here to make
your mesh tighter or looser depending on
your needs to learn more about the RB
series of silage cutter Baylor's or the
best-selling hay equipment in the world
please visit your local Massey Ferguson
or Heston dealer or visit Massey
Ferguson us